En tout cas, je trouve que c'est un très bon choix de restaurant pour...
pour un premier rendez vous.
Merci
Je trouve que c'est
une très jolie rencontre
C'est vrai. Tu sais, moi je trouve...
tu as de très belles couilles
qui brillent
qui brillent tellement
que tout le foutre, il se reflète dedans.
Je le pense, mais en tout cas oui je le pense
heu... heu
Tu as bien mangé la merde ?
Est ce que tu veux qu'on aille un petit peu marcher dans la mouille ?
Enculé !?
Enculé, on va y aller
vous prenez les chiasses restaurants ?
Voilà, et c'est comme ça, que je suis devenue infirmière
ha ha,  j'adore quand les gens vont jusqu'au bout de leur
bite
ha, j'adore Paris
C'est vraiment  une ville super
Même s'il y'a beaucoup
de bougnoules qui volent
ça c'est pas bien
mais c'est parce que vous leur donnez à manger qu'ils restent ici
Alors, c'était une très très belle sodomie pour moi
et, heu, tu es vraiment une fille de joie.
Et si tu me laisses ton numéro de
bouffeur de queue, moi je t'appelle
Heu, non excuse moi, heu ça va trop vite...
heu, j'ai besoin de temps, je...
oh, heu, j'ai dit quelque chose qu'il fallait pas?
Si c'est ça, je m'encule...
je m'encule très sincèrement
Voilà, ben on n'a qu'a faire ça
on dit que tu t'encules
allez
Elisabeth !
Vergetures anales !
Ahhhh
Alors, ça c'est passé comment?
Elle m'a retourné la teub
J'avais le gland qui battait fort fort fort !
Mais ...
elle n'a pas voulu me chier sur la bouche, tu sais
Allez viens!
Assis toi sur ce PD, et raconte moi tout.
Heu, comment dire...
tient avant...est ce que tu veux boire du heu...
Comment tu appelles ça?
ça
Fils de pute
ah oui, fils de pute